the FBI's office of Professional
Responsibility has recommended that
former deputy director Andrew McCabe be
fired from the bureau for serious
misconduct according to news reports the
recommendation comes because McCabe
authorized disclosing sensitive
information to reporters leaking
illegally and then lied to investigators
about it when they asked McCabe is
already announced his retirement which
was set to take effect on Sunday if he's
fired before then he could lose some of
the benefits he is due from the federal
government tax tax dollars Joe Joe Genoa
is a former US Attorney for the District
of Columbia and he joins us tonight Joe
thanks for coming on so I just wanted to
I want to clear the air on this specific
question I'm not an expert I'm watching
that lady and the afternoons over at
MSNBC scream about how this is immoral
to punish this guy has he done something
worth punishment do you think he's done
a number of things worth punishment
including careening through obstruction
of justice by from the beginning of the
Trump campaign doing everything he could
to exonerate Hillary Clinton in the
email server case corruptly and then if
Hillary didn't win the presidency to
figure out a way to falsely claim that
Donald Trump had committed a crime even
though that's not what he's being fired
for that certainly ultimately what he
should be assigned responsibility for he
should be fired he should have been
fired a long time ago and if he loses
some of his benefits that's good for the
country it's the least that can be done
to him what are the consequences of
having high-level law enforcement
officers who have the power of life and
death over the rest of us lying caught
lying what does that mean for us it
means that the system of equal justice
has been rent asunder by the conduct of
James Comey America's best known dirty
cop Andrew McCabe and others including
senior Obama administration Justice
Department officials this is a moment in
history that has sullied the reputation
of the FBI and the Department of Justice
and deservedly so every one of these
people should be put in a wanted poster
at a post office even
though they may never be arrested what
they have done to the department and the
FBI is undermine the confidence of the
American pet people in federal law
enforcement it is disgraceful and it all
stems from their animus toward president
Trump it is despicable so the media are
supposed to be watchdogs ever vigilant
against the abuse of power this would be
a profound abuse of power if true why
are they making excuses for it do you
think they're making excuses for it
because they like Comey and McCabe and
the senior Obama DOJ people hate Donald
Trump and they believe that anything
including violating every known standard
of federal law enforcement is justified
to either keep him from office or if
elected take him out of office it is one
of the worst moments in American history
of American law enforcement and the
shame is on Comey and everybody
associated with it so it's a procedural
matter if an FBI official is caught
lying to internal investigators to their
IG or who whatever department within the
bureau did the investigation isn't that
just prima facie cause for firing right
there it is and it's also a violation of
the false statement federal statute and
it's a crime huh because it's a crime
for you or meet a lot of the FBI correct
it is indeed and it's a crime for mr.
McCabe to do so
so Mike Flynn has seen his life
destroyed because he lied to the FBI
supposedly pled to it
michaei belies the FBI and
what's-her-name over at MSNBC screams
but how you might be punished for it
unbelievably the the people in the media
have given up on being objective or
caring about anything than hating Trump
shame on them yeah I mean rule-of-law
kind of bigger than Trump I would say
maybe but Joe thank you great to see you
my pleasure